(bright music)
- [Narrator] In the
southern part of Croatia,
in the peninsula of Peljesac,
there is a winemaker that does
things a little differently.
- [Narrator] That's right.
This winery ages their wine 75 feet
beneath the sea's surface.
(playful music)
After growing up around
many traditional winemakers,
Edi had an idea to combine
his two favorite pastimes:
Scuba diving and drinking wine.
So he decided to try
and age wine in the sea.
- [Narrator] To avoid any leaks in these
ancient storage jars,
Edi uses a glass bottle
to keep the wine in and saltwater out.
He uses custom-made cages
that line the sea floor
to hold the wine in place.
- [Narrator] And to Edi, it's the silence
that differentiates his unique
underwater wine from the pack.
(electronic beep)